marriage you felt like is it was an
oppressive structure for women could you
talk more about that you said something
like that earlier i don't think it's an
oppressive thing now okay but i think
the institution as a whole yeah i mean
look it's
for hundreds of years it was women being
told who they had to marry and not who
they could love open and freely right
and i just think that you know
the fact is that no woman has a last
name that is her own right you know even
if she chooses to keep her last name
that's her father's last name it's just
it just seems a little bit crazy to me
that every you know what i mean i'm not
crazy to me because i know this is just
how things work but um at the same time
i don't think we should have to buy into
it like that you know what i mean i just
don't think that we we need to carry on
i think we could have successful
relationships without the institution of
marriage you know what i mean signing a
contract to say oh i'm gonna love you
till the day i die i'm gonna be there in
sickness and in health and blah blah
blah mate listen as soon as [ __ ] as
soon as women get sick men run out the
door so
yeah i mean so